life
okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see uh
a bunch of questions here
let's see how about one from morten here
why does an electron fall
or go to a lower orbit
after being in an excited state
okay that requires explaining various
things
okay so first point atoms
in the center of atom is its nucleus
made of protons and nuclear neutrons and
then outside there are electrons people
often say the electrons are orbiting
the center of the atom that's kind of a
a rather idealized way to think about
what's going on but more or less you
could start off by thinking that
and the the nucleus is pretty small
compared to where the
the uh electrons orbit um the the
nucleus is about a hundred thousand
times um
uh smaller than the sort of the radius
of the of the orbit so to speak
why does an electron quotes orbit the
nucleus well the nucleus is made of
protons which are positively charged and
neutrons which are neutral
electrically neutral and electrons are
negatively charged and there's just a
rule about electricity that
unlike charges attract so positive
charge in nucleus attracts the negative
charge which is the electron and it kind
of keeps the electron from sort of just
floating away um out into the distance
and it keeps it sort of in somewhere
near the nucleus now why does the
electron not just given that there's
this force of attraction between the
nucleus and the electron why does the
electron not just get pulled right into
the nucleus and then go splat there why
doesn't it just sort of crash into the
nucleus
well that fact that the electron doesn't
do that is what led people to
one of the main things that led people
to invent quantum mechanics and quantum
theory about 100 years ago
uh it's an observation that electrons
can't just
in order for the electron to just sort
of spiraling towards the nucleus it has
to change the amount of energy that it
has it has to sort of continuously
change the amount of energy that it has
as it goes in towards the nucleus it
will gradually have less and less force
of attraction less and less potential
energy maybe more kinetic energy of
motion as it as it spirals faster and so
on it has to change the amount of energy
that it has in some continuous way and
sort of one of the key observations of
quantum mechanics is that electrons
don't do that
instead when they are confined within an
atom at least they have a discrete set
of possible energy levels their only
an electron can have a particular energy
or some other energy or some other
energy but it can't have energies in
between those energy levels
so
in a hydrogen atom for example there's
the question of okay so what energy can
an electron have
well the way that this is thought about
sort of in the in the mathematics of
quantum theory usually a thing called
the schrodinger's equation
and schrodinger's equation is an
equation that determines uh it's
determining more or less the probability
for where an electron should be
and the equation you can think of the
relevant part of the equation as being a
little bit like the equation that
governs waves on a string so for example
if you have a a piece of string you hold
it at the two ends and you pluck it in
the middle you can you can have a mode
of the string where the thing where the
string has just got one it's just been
been plucked in the middle and it's
going bouncing back and forth like that
or you can have a mode of the string
where it's got um where it has two peaks
where it has um it's pulled out here and
it goes out again on the other side and
that's
another mode of the string
and in general with something like at
least idealized string you'll find that
there are modes of the string
which have uh both the the the lowest
frequency where it just has a single
kind of hump then the next frequency
where it has two humps then one where it
has three humps and so on and the
frequency is can go up it can be any
whole number any integer number of humps
that it can have but it can't have three
and a half humps because if it had three
and a half humps the last hump wouldn't
be sort of over and if you attach the
string at at a particular level then you
would be sort of in the middle of a hump
where you want to attach the string and
that wouldn't work so as soon as you
have say i'm attaching the string at
this fixed level here and then i'm going
to let it bow out in one direction or
the other um you have to have a fixed
set of possible modes of the string
so that exact same thing happens in the
mathematics children's equation for an
electron in a hydrogen atom or an atom
um that there are a certain number of
possible modes that the electron can
exist in
and the lowest mode is something where
more or less it just has a single this
so-called wave function for the electron
just has a single peak and if you have
if you go to the next mode it kind of
has two peaks and so on it's it's pretty
much like waves on it like these um
modes of a string
although the detailed mathematics is a
bit different
um if you're into these things the um
for modes on a string they're
trigonometric functions sine sine
functions cosine functions and so on
for um uh in a for um the um
wave function uh for like a single
electron in a hydrogen atom which has
just one proton the the relevant
functions are things called spherical
harmonics which are the 3d
generalization of sine of sine functions
together with things called lager
polynomials which are the things that
determine the kind of radial behavior of
uh
as a function of distance from the from
the nucleus but the main point is
because of the electrical attraction of
the electron to the nucleus it's held
sort of in this fixed region more or
less
just as kind of you're imagining a
string held in a fixed way
and it's that together with the fact
that this just fact about quantum
mechanics that leads the electron to
just have this discrete set of possible
energy levels um and those discrete
energy levels you can have an electron
in its ground state its lowest energy
level or its first excited state or a
second excited state and so on and so on
and so on in the case of a hydrogen atom
simplest kind of atom with just one
proton one electron the energy levels
are roughly spaced like uh one over n
squared the the nth level is roughly um
it uh as you go towards um
the point at which the electron which
you pump so much energy into the
electron the electron just uh says i'm
out of here and escapes from the from
the atomic nucleus um as you approach
that point you have lots and lots of
energy levels all uh all kind of um
accumulating together but it's that
there's just that simple formula that
tells you the energy levels um for an
electron in a hydrogen atom
so
the um
uh the question was
what happens when an electron is in an
excited state
and then decays into the ground state
so
there are all kinds of ways the electron
can wind up in an excited state
for example
you could uh have
the the the atom at a high temperature
what does that mean the temperature it
tells you that how fast the atom is just
running around the the energy associated
with just the motion of the atom and
when an atom is kind of running around
in a gas or something it will collide
with other atoms and those collisions
will will will as those collisions
happen they're essentially electrical
forces that get imposed on the electron
in the atom and the electron will be
pushed to a higher energy level
and the kind of rules of quantum
mechanics say that the electron has to
be pushed from one energy level to the
next energy level to the next energy
level it can't be anywhere in between
those it has to make these jumps between
energy levels
and
the now actually to be a little bit more
accurate about what quantum mechanics
really says
there's this thing called the
uncertainty principle in quantum
mechanics which essentially tells you
this thing
where
you
have
it's got to be at a particular energy
level
that applies if you're going to say
that's what the atom is like and it's
staying that way but if you say what can
happen just for a very brief time you
can actually have something which is not
quite what you would expect from oh it's
got this energy level there's a there's
a an uncertainty in the energy and what
happens is the uncertainty in the energy
is inversely proportional to the
uncertainty in the time so to speak
so that means if you wait a really long
time the energy is very very precisely
defined if you wait only a very short
time if you look at things only in a
very short time interval the energy can
can fluctuate
and so
but in any case once when you have an
atom that's kind of running around in a
gas the electrons can get energy given
to them they can end up in excited
states
now the question is what will happen
into a to an electron that is in that
excited state
and the answer is
that
in in
the electron will have
some probability
to emit a photon
and
and uh jump down to the lower state so
why does it do that well
uh there are a variety of ways to think
about this one way to think about it is
some
see what's the best way to think about
it
well
uh we could think about it again it's
it's kind of a rule about quantum
mechanics
that says there is a certain probability
for a an electron to emit a photon and
that's some
uh that's something where
the um
again this is a little complicated okay
if you have an electron and it's just
going along and it's just sort of freely
moving
through through the vacuum
then
the it's not possible for the electron
to emit a photon because momentum
conservation prevents that that
if if the if you you can't um
you can't arrange to conserve momentum
and and do that
so what ends up happening
well
actually that's not
yeah you you okay here's the problem if
you've got an electron
then it can't emit a photon and stay
being an electron
you could have one thing that's pretty
common in particle physics is you have
unstable particles you have one type of
particle
like
i don't know
a uh a pion for example and after some
amount of time this pion has some mass
and after some amount of time the the
there's the there's a distribution it's
an exponential distribution of how long
it takes but after some it has some
lifetime and on average after a certain
amount of time the pion will just break
up into two particles
but neither of those final particles can
be a pion because energy and momentum
conservation can't which uh can't still
work if one of those final particles is
the same as one of the initial particles
so if an electron is just tooling along
that's just happily going through the
vacuum it can't just emit an actual
photon
um if you kick the electron with some
other force
then absolutely the electron can emit a
photon
and so
what happens in
one way to think about it is
that at any given moment an electron has
some chance of emitting a photon but it
can't actually do it unless it's sort of
been kind of kicked and given some
momentum for example
well when an electron is held inside
uh inside an atom it's constantly being
kind of kicked by the forces that keep
the the electron kind of in orbit in a
sense in the atom
more exactly
the
there's this idea of virtual photons a
real photon is a photon that it's
emitted and it can go off and it can
survive for millions of years and it can
just go through go through space forever
a virtual photon just like i mentioned
there's this uncertainty principle that
talks about how you can have a variation
of energy for a sufficiently short time
and for a short enough time there can be
a variation of energy so similarly that
same kind of uncertainty principle idea
has the feature that for a short enough
time even the number of particles that
you thought you had isn't something that
is fixed so there's sort of an
uncertainty idea it's a general idea of
quantum mechanics and it's fancier
version quantum field theory that says
if you if you are only dealing with a
short enough time interval there's sort
of even uncertainty in the number of
particles you thought you had and so
what that allows to happen is that an
electron can emit virtual photons which
it then reabsorbs again a very short
time afterwards so for for some brief
period of time
you might have thought you had one
particle but actually you have two it's
an electron and a virtual photon
okay so
electrical forces of like the the atomic
nucleus keeping the electron in in its
orbit
those can be thought about as a lots of
exchange of virtual photons between the
nucleus and the electron and so those
virtual photons are sort of continually
kicking the electron that is in its
orbit so to speak around the nucleus and
those kicks allow the possibility of the
electron emitting an actual photon an
actual particle of light
and so
what happens is there's some chance that
it does that
uh if it's going to do that it has to
emit a photon whose energy is exactly
the difference of energies between the
excited if it's in the burst excited
state between that excited state and the
ground state and so because that's the
only amount of energy that you could
allow to be emitted because the the
electron has to wind up jumping down to
the low energy state but so with some
chance when the thing is in that excited
state it will emit a photon and because
it's continually being kicked so it has
the chance to emit a photon and uh with
some probability after some amount of
time on average it will emit a photon
and jump down to the lower uh lower
state when it emits that photon it
produces that might produce visible
light if it's at the right um right
energy difference
and that's for example the visible light
that you see in a fluorescent light bulb
um that's the um
what's happening is that there have been
uh atoms that have been sort of uh with
electrons have been excited in that case
by electric discharge and um the um
uh the the uh the electrons are kind of
jumping down to the lower state emitting
a photon of a particular energy and so
if you looked at the uh the frequencies
of the light that were emitted there'll
be these these specific spectral lines
as they're called specific frequencies
of light that are being emitted
associated with the specific uh jumping
down from an excited state to the ground
state for the atom
so that's a sorry this is actually got a
little bit more complicated than i
thought it requires explaining a little
bit of quantum mechanics and things to
see how that works but that's kind of
the idea
of uh
why the electron uh sort of jumps down
to the lower stages there's always this
possibility of emitting a photon and
as soon as that happens it can jump down
to the lower state or has to jump down
to the lower state uh just in in sort of
uh
there are more complicated things that
can happen with very low probability
like you can emit two photons and they
can have slightly different energies and
things like that but most of the time
it's you're in an excited state you emit
a single photon you jump down to the
lower state
let's see
oh boy there's a question from vuk here
what does the fact that there are
infinite number of decimals between two
integers tell us about the nature of the
world okay well let's first of all talk
about what that means so we have numbers
0 1 2 3 etc
in between 0 and 1
there are
an infinite number of numbers that you
can name there's you know point one
there's point zero one there's point one
one one one two three four five six
these are all decimal numbers and
there's an infinite number of decimal
numbers that fit in between
any two integers like zero and one
and so
the um
uh this question
of whether
the um
uh this so there's there's this kind of
uh they're an infinite number of
integers zero one two three four five
you can keep counting forever but
between any two integers they're an
infinite number of so-called real
numbers that you can specify with
decimals and each of those decimals the
reason that in a sense that they're an
infinite number of real numbers is that
each one of those decimals can keep
going forever so you can just make a
change to a digit that's the billionth
digit
and that will give you a new real number
and it's incredibly close to the real
number you had before but you can pack
an infinite number of real numbers in
between let's say zero and one
now things get kinda tricky because you
can ask questions like
uh well what about rational numbers what
about numbers of the form two-thirds or
three-quarters or whatever else
and
you can say as you go
and um
uh and look at uh sort of all possible
numbers that you can make from rational
numbers that also you can pack an
infinite number of those things in
between zero and one
and so those are those are two different
kinds of ways to get an infinite number
of numbers between zero and one one is
you just pick the digits in the decimal
expansion and another is you form them
by taking two integers and you say this
integer divided by that integer those
are sort of two ways to pack infinite
numbers of numbers in between zero and
one and they're are subtle mathematical
things we could separately talk about
that have to do with sort of the the
difference in thinking about those two
different kinds of ways to pack infinite
numbers of numbers into this interval of
the real line so to speak
okay what does this tell us about the
nature of the world was the question
i think it tells us less than we might
think it tells us
because i don't think that our physical
universe is capable of representing
those precise real numbers that exist
those infinite number of precise real
numbers that let's say exist between
zero and one
so it used to be thought
that for example
if you
if you look at space
if you just say i have a point i can
pick its position i can give it
coordinates those coordinates can be
arbitrary numbers with as many decimal
digits as i want used to be thought that
it was perfectly okay
in the universe to just say i've got one
point here that has these coordinates
i've got another point here that it's
infinitesimally away that has this
coordinate that differs only in the
billionth digit
and i can pack as many points as i want
into an arbitrarily small region of
space that's what people used to used to
think
uh actually a long time ago people used
to think similar things about fluids
like water that you could like be at any
position in some water because it's just
a continuous fluid
but then about 150 years ago it became
clear that no that's not true about
water you can't just be at any position
in water because water is actually made
of discrete molecules and you either are
at the position of a molecule or between
molecules and you can't just sort of
pick an absolutely arbitrary position to
be at in something like a fluid like
water so the question is how does this
work for space one of the things that's
come out of our big effort to find a
fundamental theory of physics in the
last couple of years has been really
pretty good evidence that space like
water consists of discrete things and it
isn't the case that you can put
uh that in fact space there are sort of
atoms of space
they're much more ideal ideal i kind of
idealize things than physical atoms like
of hydrogen or something they're they're
just sort of these elements
that make up the universe they're kind
of the ultimate elements that make up
the universe but you can think of them
as playing the role of kind of atoms of
space and space consists of this huge
number of these sort of discrete points
so it isn't the case that you can just
sort of you say well where can i go in
space well you can go at any of these
points the positions of any of these
atoms of space but you can't in some
sense go anywhere between them now we
don't we can't tell that space is made
of discrete atoms of space because
we don't really know the scale yet but
perhaps
the scale of the distance between sort
of neighboring atoms of space might be
something like 1 trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillionth of a meter
so really really small incredibly much
smaller than for example the size of a
proton
um
and uh uh we don't know how big
electrons are so far as we can tell
electrons in experiments so far they
look like they're infinitely small i
don't think that's really the case i
think that actually electrons are quite
big compared to this kind of elementary
length this sort of shortest distance
between atoms of space
but as soon as you imagine that the
universe consists of discrete points
discrete atoms of space it no longer
becomes possible to say oh we'll just
pick an arbitrary position
now the um
there are so so this idea that we can
use real numbers to represent things in
the universe ultimately i don't think
that can be true ultimately i think that
there are just discrete positions that
you can have for example
now it is the case though that the
mathematics that you can get by assuming
that things are continuous assuming that
you can just vary things arbitrarily
small amounts that you vary something an
arbitrary small amount um something else
will vary in arbitrarily small amounts
and so on that you can talk about
arbitrarily tiny variations and the
effect of arbitrary tiny variations
that's a very useful thing in
mathematics and that's one of the core
things that leads on to calculus for
example and it's a it's a very useful
assumption in mathematics and a lot of
mathematical structure can be built on
top of this kind of assumption of
continuity so
at least as an approximation to what
happens in the real world
it's an important thing to use because
it allows you to build this kind of
tower of mathematics i don't think it's
what how it actually works in the real
world i think that there will be
situations we imagine there might be
some in kind of extreme versions of
black holes and other rather exotic
things but you can actually see through
to the atoms of space you can actually
see that space is discrete you can tell
it's kind of like a kind of a
gravitational analog or microscope but
you're kind of seeing down to the
smallest scales of space and you can
tell that it's no longer continuous just
like there are experiments you can do on
water that show that yes it's actually
made of discrete molecules not something
continuous
so i think the answer is that that i
view kind of the idea of real numbers
and the idea of sort of continuous
variation you can go arbitrarily closely
to get from one number to the next i
view that as being a useful idealization
that lets you build a bunch of
mathematics but not really the way the
world actually works
so there's a question here
um
okay
it's a question from m rector what is a
time crystal
i believe that term was invented by
a chap i know named frank wilcheck who's
a physicist
um
uh but so i'm going to i'm going to say
what my interpretation of it is
um and uh i hope i'm i hope i'm right in
this
so first of all what is a crystal
the defining feature of a crystal is
that there are atoms arranged in a
particular way and as you move around
the crystal you'll always find atoms
arranged in the same way
so for example a salt crystal a sodium
chloride crystal the atoms are arranged
essentially in a cubic grid
so they just arranged like uh um like i
don't know
uh i was going to say like an egg crate
but i think it egg crates i haven't seen
an egg crate in decades so i'm not sure
that's a useful analogy but they're
they're basically just arranged um you
know in a
you know understand a square grid a
cubic grid that's how the the atoms are
arranged in a sodium chloride crystal
and the defining feature of it being a
crystal is
that it is if you move to a different
part of the crystal you're still see
it's arranged in a cubic way and if you
you
you know that
if you're in this particular position in
the crystal and you move by a certain
number of so-called lattice spacings
the um or a certain number of the of
multiples of the size of the unit cell
the thing that just contains uh the sort
of the defining unit which is a cube in
the case of a cubic thing in the case of
sodium chloride if you move around uh by
the by the sort of size of that unit
cell you'll just keep getting copies of
that unit cell the crystal will always
keep looking the same so that's how an
ordinary crystal works there are
uh let's see
17 i think different kinds of
arrangements
of possible sort of arrangements of
lattices for three-dimensional crystals
um there's like the way the diamond
crystals work there's ways that uh
hexagonal close-packed crystals which
are like packed where the atoms are
packed in the way that you people pack
spherical fruit in a grocery store and
so on there are different kinds of
packings um for the different kinds of
ways to arrange those unit cells and the
the mathematics of group theory tells
one that there are a limited number so i
remember correctly there are 17 of these
um so-called bravais lattices um that uh
define the possible arrangements that
you can have
um and so that's how crystals work
that's how ordinary crystals work uh
they are crystals in space
so there are other kinds of crystals
another kind of crystal is a liquid
crystal what is a liquid crystal
well a liquid crystal
what
there are a bunch of um
liquid crystal molecules often
cholesterol-like molecules which are
long stringy molecules and they have a
definite kind of direction to them
and what happens in a liquid crystal is
the molecules are sort of bouncing
around in all different places but
what makes them sort of crystalline is
that they are lined up they're all these
all these kinds of um directions so in
direction there is this kind of order
that exists just like in the case of an
ordinary crystal
in position there's a certain kind of
order that exists
so the idea of a time crystal is to say
let's imagine something which is
changing through time
you can have something where
there is
a
uh the thing kind of repeats itself in
time just like in an ordinary crystal
the thing repeats itself in space
and i'm not sure what i mean that there
are many phenomena
where
the thing will tend to be
um where something will happen
periodically in time you have a pendulum
it's swinging backwards and forwards
it's periodic in time the idea of a time
crystal i think is that you have
something where there are many many
different components just like there are
many different atoms in a crystal and an
ordinary crystal and they're all
arranged in certain way in space i think
in a time crystal the idea is that there
are many components that are all uh
having this sort of order in time
um i'm not sure
i think that's that's the idea there
um
let's see
so question from
okay let's let's change topic completely
there's a question from wraith
what is my opinion on the technological
and economic feasibility of asteroid
mining
um
you know the world is a very strange
place when okay so first of all
uh
yeah i was going to say about asteroid
mining
um
somehow it's a it's a staple of kind of
science fiction
let's go to asteroids and and go uh go
mine something interesting from
asteroids you know i i'm kind of waiting
for the day when somebody identifies a
golden asteroid where there's an
asteroid that's all made of gold
one of the things that's weird about
minerals mining
those kinds of things
is
that
there are places where there are a lot
where there's a deposit where there's
lots of some kind of mineral and there
are other places where there's none of
it
like on the earth there are places where
we say oh yeah that's a great place for
copper mining or oh there's a uh you
know molybdenum you can get molybdenum
here or oh this is a place where you can
get uh europium or some some other
obscure element
so
and there are you know around the world
there are places where there's specific
places where there are gold mines
uranium mines you know there even if you
go to colorado there are cities named
after the different kinds of uh uh of of
of elements and minerals that that got
mine there back in the day and so on
um and um
it so for some reason on the earth for
example there will be particular places
where there's a big deposit of gold or a
big deposit of molybdenum
and
that happens presumably
when the earth was formed
and
as sort of all all these different
chemical elements were part of kind of
this molten uh
thing that was forming the earth
and
various processes of oh there's this
temperature gradient that causes this
thing to go to this place and just
wanted to go to that place and that sort
of separated these different things and
wind them up being in different places
i must say that i find it a little bit
confusing because i don't think might be
wrong about this but i don't think in
the sun for example i don't think there
are similarly places where if you look
at the look at the sun and maybe that's
just the outer layers of the sun that
this is the case i don't think it's true
that you can say oh there's a very
helium-rich part of the sun there's a
very hydrogen-rich part of the sun i
think it's pretty uniform and but for
whatever reason the crust of the earth
is not that way and so we have definite
deposits of this there and you know some
country can really luck out you know
um
you know rwanda can really luck out and
having a lot of tantalum ore and its
rocks or whatever else it is
and um the uh
that's um so there's segregation of
where things go and similarly in the
asteroid belt of these little fragments
of of rock basically that mostly orbit
between the orbits of mars and jupiter
and that were presumably things that
were never accreted into planets
when the uh when the solar system formed
or conceivably some of them are the
result of collisions between planets
that sort of self-destructed and turned
into a bunch of pieces of
rubble so to speak
um but within the asteroid belt there
are similarly uh there seem to be
asteroids that are made you know very
rich in one material very rich in other
material and so you can imagine going
and finding the golden asteroid so to
speak
um now the question is what do you do
with a golden asteroid you have to go
and uh
go and send a spacecraft there
and um and and sort of uh bring you know
their various different schemes if it's
a small enough asteroid you can imagine
just attaching rocket engines to the
asteroid and turning it into a rocket
and just bringing it back to earth
it's a little bit like back in the day
people used to take icebergs from the
arctic for example and they used to tow
them through the atlantic for example
down to like new york city and places
like that before before air conditioning
and so on and refrigeration was really
so much of a thing
and the the rate at which the ice melts
is slow enough that you can get the
iceberg you know all the way to new york
and then start chopping pieces off it to
um to deliver ice to people and so it's
sort of that's a one approach that's
reminiscent of that is just put put a
bunch of rockets on a little asteroid
and have it um come over and uh you know
wind up in earth orbit or something like
this or maybe even uh make it re-enter
the earth's atmosphere i'm not sure if
that's possible i don't know how much
you lose of the asteroid if you if you
have it uh operate like a meteorite so
to speak
um
there are all kinds of questions about
if you go out and stake a claim to an
asteroid like what who owns the
asteroids and there are various treaties
that some countries have subscribed to
about sort of ownership of things in
outer space and i kind of think it's
it's probably at this point if somebody
actually went and staked a claim to an
asteroid it's probably for all practical
purposes they're asteroid um but it's
not uh not completely clear how that
works um but so that's sort of an issue
in in in the case of mineral rights
there's a very well-defined protocol for
how you sort of stake a claim
and um then are able to make use of
those minerals in a particular place on
the earth
the the question
of um
uh
different schemes for mining asteroids
i've certainly seen a few of these
sort of plans for how you would do it
i have
no idea if it makes any economic sense i
think that it's one of these things
where
you know
mining it for gold it's kind of a weird
idea because you know if if it is the
case that you tow the giant golden
asteroid into earth orbit the price of
gold where people have hoarded gold you
know to to maintain uh to sort of
represent the value of some currency or
some such other thing the the hoarding
of gold it's all going to get
get completely broken if somebody shows
up in earth orbit with a giant golden
asteroid i mean the same kind of thing
happened back oh what was it 30 years
ago something with the price of silver
people the price of silver was going up
and up and up and eventually it became
clear
that at some point people will take well
random silver spoons they have but also
could actually mine more silver out of
the ground and although it's expensive
to do that mining at some point
it means oh there's tons more silver and
so the the price of silver went went way
down and i kind of think that's what
would happen if somebody shows up with a
golden asteroid in earth orbit now you
know there are other kinds of materials
where you say
uh you know we really need more
pick your material you know let's say
that the the cold fusion um
scheme that used palladium uh had really
worked and people were like we really
need more palladium well let's say the
high-temperature superconductor scheme
that used lanthanum had really worked
you know we need tons of lanthanum but
it's a so-called rare earth element
on on the earth and there's not very
much of it
um i can tell you a funny story from a
slightly obscure element gallium it has
become more commonly used in the
intervening years but back in the
in the
uh earlyish 1980s
um
i was
uh
interacting with some physicists who
really needed 10 tons of gallium
okay and why do they need 10 tons of
gallium they were going to use it as a
detector for neutrinos and they were
just going to take the 10 tons of
gallium stick it in a mine somewhere for
for 10 years
you know have all kinds of detectors
that allowed you to detect particles
going through it and they were going to
give it back to somebody and at that
time i kind of investigated the question
how much gallium actually is there in
the world and who has it
and it turns out there were about 10
tons of gallium that had been mined and
were stockpiled at that time so that
gives you some some kind of sense of how
much
of some of one of these kind of rare
materials exists
and clearly if you find an asteroid made
of gallium it'll be a lot well the the
typical you know you can find asteroids
much bigger than 10 tons so if there's
one very rich in gallium it could be a
good thing now in fact i think much more
gallium has been found since then i
think people just didn't care about
mining it was mined along with aluminum
back in those days but i think nobody
really needed it for anything so nobody
bothered to mine it and as it became
needed for various electronic components
um people started actually mining it and
refining it and so on
so i'm i but i was going to say at the
beginning of this
um
the uh
the question
of um asteroid mining it was a couple of
years ago i had uh
was um
it was a company that was an asteroid
mining company now obviously it's not in
production in operation because there
are no asteroids being mined right now
but it was a company that was kind of
making the plans for mining asteroids
and um
uh it ended up being bought
by a blockchain company and it's like
this is a very strange thing in the
world and i happen to run into the ceo
of the of the um
asteroid mining company and i was like
why did this blockchain company buy you
it wasn't the coincidence of the word
mining in asteroid mining and mining as
in
the um uh
the idea of mining for proof of work in
blockchains and things
um
and it's like well it wasn't quite that
but
not clear how close it wasn't to that so
to speak uh of course the other thing
that is interesting about things like
asteroids and asteroid mining and so on
is this uh kind of almost legalistic
question about staking claims to
asteroids and kind of what how you
remake kind of property laws when you're
dealing with uh extraterrestrial objects
and and so on
let's see
uh
boy there's a question here
um
okay there's a question from ori
how does sophisticated philosophy relate
to sophisticated math in the thinking
processes underlying them and the
intellectual firepower and effect
it's an interesting question
so
you know mathematics
is a very
it's a thing where you can build a very
tall tower
you have
some ideas in mathematics
and
on top of those elementary ideas like
adding numbers together you know you get
powers of numbers then you get numbers
of different kinds then you get sort of
ways to factor numbers you get ways to
combine numbers you build this big big
big tower of different kinds of
knowledge and so mathematics as it
exists today a lot of the top of the
tower
involves kind of many steps from kind of
elementary notions like notions of whole
numbers and notions of uh i don't know
angles or something like this the thing
that's built is a very tall tower
and
that's kind of the nature of
mathematical
work is that there's this kind of tall
tower of concepts that build on top of
each other
let's contrast that with philosophy
in philosophy it tends to be the case
that there are difficult concepts
but there is much less of this
phenomenon of things building in a tower
it's much more
that you know questions that were asked
by plato back a couple of thousand years
ago are still reasonable questions you
can ask today and you can reason about
those questions and the arguments have
changed and gotten a bit more
sophisticated and there are a few more
steps but there's nothing like the kind
of giant tower that gets built in
mathematics
once still dealing with sort of
philosophy the methodology is much more
about
can we
take this
this rock that's been around for a long
time and can we polish it in a new way
rather than can we build a big tower of
rocks
and look only at the rock at the top so
to speak it's a somewhat different
kind of practice of um
of activity and that's why for example
when you look at a philosophy paper it
might routinely refer to papers that are
500 years thousands of years old whereas
in mathematics that will be much rarer
in mathematics the things that were
figured out by gauss and euler and so on
most research mathematics has long ago
kind of covered those things in more
layers of abstraction and built more
sort of sophisticated concepts on top of
that
now in terms of the type of thinking
that's involved in these different areas
uh i i can't say i'm a full native in
either of these areas um but i would say
that
my
um
my observation
is that sort of the mode of work in
philosophy is the medium of explanation
is basically natural language
you explain philosophy by writing essays
about it mostly
there's a few areas of philosophy which
have some notational kinds of things but
mostly
you write essays about things whereas in
mathematics
most of the explanation is done at the
level of sort of formal mathematical
presentation in the sort of mathematical
language that exists for mathematics
there is no similar language for
philosophy
back in the 1600s people talked about
making a philosophical language which
would be some kind of formal notation
for the kinds of ideas that might occur
both in sort of everyday discourse and
in the kinds of things one talks about
in philosophy whether it's about ethics
or or epistemology or any of these
different areas
uh that effort to make a philosophical
language didn't really get off the
ground in the 1600s
i think actually there's the chance to
do it again now
and in fact the things i built with kind
of computational language as a way in
wolfram language for example to
represent the world computationally
that's kind of going in the direction of
making something like this kind of
philosophical language
if we have a kind of formal
philosophical language then we may be
able to start building towers and
philosophy much as we have built towers
in mathematics ever since mathematical
notation was invented which is basically
400 years ago
and and that's that's what began the
towers of things like algebra and
calculus and and so on beyond that
in terms of actual people
who
do mathematics versus do philosophy
i i must say i've noticed some
some things which are kind of
interesting
like
in
in many areas of of science
if you're talking to a scientist
they'll kind of be just listening for
the point they just want to know you
know you've got one punchy point to make
it's like this is the result theorem in
mathematics
you know some observational fact and
physics whatever else it's like listen
for the point
and
they don't really read all the details
and so on and so on and so on
philosophers on the other hand tend to
be not that way they tend to actually
read the details because that's where
their content really is
it's not there's just one punchy point
it's not oh we can summarize
wittgenstein by one sentence it's the
the the you know the message is in that
whole sort of essay structure that
builds up those ideas so it's a little
different in mathematics people will say
well tell me the theorem okay great now
show me the proof of the theorem okay
that helps me to understand the context
of the theorem maybe if it's an
automated proof it probably doesn't help
you with very much
but if it's a handmade proof it's part
of the exposition of the theorem itself
so that's sort of a difference in in the
way that works
in terms of
you know you can ask questions i i
always think it's kind of a silly
question to um it's a it's a dumb
question to ask how smart the people are
who do different kinds of things
um because i don't think there's really
a meaning to that i think that if you
look at the kind of terms of mind
required in philosophy and in
mathematics
i have the impression i might be wrong
that there is more diversity in the
types of ways to do mathematics than
there are in the types of ways to do
philosophy i think in philosophy it's
really about
keeping you know keeping the argument in
mind so to speak and being able to
figure out how all the different things
that sort of
emerge in that argument and how you how
you clarify the argument so that you can
go and take the next step and so on in
mathematics there tend to be people who
have a very formal approach where it's
like we've got this formal structure we
can calculate from it that people have a
rather more intuitive aesthetic approach
we say we just imagine these concepts
and we can just sort of see them flowing
around and this must fit with that and
this or that way
that people who have a very geometrical
view of things of you know i can just
imagine these different objects even if
they're in you know infinite dimensional
space or whatever else i kind of have a
geometrical way of thinking about that
that people who have a much more
algebraic way of thinking about things
where it's really like give me the
formal structure written down in symbols
and see what consequences it has
the um
so
that that's uh that's a little bit on
the on kind of the um
um
the sort of um
uh a little bit of at least how i see
the relationship between kind of the
things people do in philosophy and in in
mathematics
that both of them when done well
involve a clarity of of thought and
presentation that is somewhat similar
i would say that philosophy tends to be
the catch-all field of if you can't
figure out anything beyond what you can
figure out by just words then it's
philosophy if there's a formalism if
there's some kind of structured way of
approaching it as there is in
mathematics then it's not philosophy
and i think that
in
what tends to happen is that things
fields
when philosophy has been
in in sort of a a top field and has been
at various times in history that has
been quite common for fields to be kind
of born in philosophy and then they
develop a serious notation and a serious
kind of formalism and then they sort of
drop out of philosophy and become their
own field i mean back in the day physics
used to be called natural philosophy and
was thought of often as a branch of
philosophy that had to do with reasoning
about the natural world but after
galileo and newton and people like that
particularly after they introduced kind
of mathematical thinking into into
physics and natural philosophy physics
kind of dropped out of the philosophy a
realm and became its own thing i mean
famously the the title of isaac newton's
1687 you know uh book principia
mathematica was
translated in into english it will be
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy so right there in the title
he was saying you know natural
philosophy which is a branch of
philosophy these are the mathematical
principles of it which eventually became
another kind of field
so i think that's um i mean for myself
i've been quite interested in um
in recent times in in questions that
have been questions of philosophy
but what i found is that there are
things that i've discovered in science
that
sort of really address those questions
in philosophy questions about
kind of what can we predict what can we
know
questions about well for example why
does the universe exist these kinds of
questions which have been questions of
philosophy i mean a question like why
does the universe exist
that's even not even philosophy says
that question is not for us and it's
often kind of been pushed to theology
for example um i mean theology
was the kind of the the big tradition uh
back
more than 500 years ago now
where there was a big sort of
intellectual tradition that was very
deeply interwoven with philosophy at
that time and was kind of the the um the
the starting point for a lot of kinds of
thinking about a lot of kinds of things
i think much of that has sort of been
taken over by more formalistic science
in in modern times um i think that uh
uh well i've just been actually thinking
about and writing about kind of the
development of different paradigms in
the history of science and i think we
can kind of identify
three historical periods and paradigms
and i think we have the makings of a
fourth one that uh are kind of
interesting but that's a different topic
which would get me far afield and i'm
happy to talk about it another time
um
let's see questions here let's see
there's a question from aaron
uh how did my parents encourage my
pursuits in science
um
i think they mostly encouraged them by
knowing almost nothing about science
that's a that's a
kind of a terrible thing to say but i
think it's it's um it of course always
depends on the personality of the child
but i think um i was very happy knowing
about things that my parents did not
know about and that happened to be
science
i could have known about lots of other
kinds of things my parents didn't know
about
but um
i
kind of learnt about science as a pretty
much a personal independent activity
not really particularly stimulated by
parents or
schools or anything like that
i just got interested in things and
started wondering about different
questions in science at the time when i
was growing up
in the 1960s the space program was a big
thing and so that was kind of a a
particular kind of
sort of thing that one was constantly
hearing about and it sounded kind of
cool and for me it represented something
which i suppose many young people think
about which is the space program was
kind of an icon of the future so to
speak
and um uh for me since i was sort of
planning to live in the future kind of
thing
that was something that was pretty
interesting to me
and from that i got interested in in
more basic kinds of science and just
reading books about science learning
stuff about science trying to figure out
things about science that was kind of
what
what happened now amusingly in terms of
what i was just saying
my mother was actually a philosophy
professor
and i suppose that my
the one thing that i might have gotten
from that
is if i would ever say anything about
science she would often say but how
could one possibly know that
about some sort of scientific result
and um so it was kind of an interesting
um
uh exercise she really knew basically
nothing about the content of science but
it was like there was a certain degree
of the way that knowledge is put
together so to speak that i think
one perhaps learns in learning about
philosophy
that
uh
certainly had the interesting effect
that if i really tried to explain
something
in um
uh that uh was kind of you had to be
able to explain it at a level where
the the sort of the structure of
knowledge made sense rather than just
well here's this random fight i'm not
sure how much i really tried explaining
uh that much there but but at least a
little bit of that um uh happened i
think my mother particularly when i was
quite young uh you know i would be
talking about things in science and she
would end up realizing that those were
good examples uh that she could use in
in philosophy lectures she was giving
and philosophy papers she wrote and so
on so no doubt some of my i am pretty
sure some of my early interests you know
the typical kid things of dinosaurs and
things like that wound up being sort of
examples and philosophy papers and so on
uh as a result of that
um
my father was
mainly
business person and sometime novelist
and again not
very science-oriented i think had been
interested in science a bit um back in
the
1940s and so on but
i think quickly decided that uh that i
knew more about science at a pretty
young age than he knew and and he would
uh just say silly things if he tried
talking about it which i don't think was
quite true or fair but but um uh but so
i would say that the
the number one feature of my sort of
life and science there was that my
parents didn't know much about it and
that was uh uh that for me was some uh
uh i actually would have been cool if
they'd known a bunch about it it would
have been would have been interesting
and um had i now that these days i'm
interested in philosophy um you know i i
i would have had much more interesting
conversations with my mother about
philosophy given that i'm now interested
in philosophy
but um but i wasn't um back when i was
much younger
so
let's see vuk asks
if knowing absolutely nothing is
represented by zero and knowing
everything is represented by one where
do you think the human race is at the
moment and what are the limits of
knowledge
you know one of the things that comes
out of studying
kind of computational kinds of ways of
thinking about the world is the
realization
that the frontiers of knowledge are
infinite
essentially it's like saying
you can
you can ask the question
given a particular
way of constructing the world
what
can you say everything about how the
world will work
can you invent every thing that will be
useful to us humans in dealing with the
world
this question about can you say
everything about how the world will work
the answer is
you for very fundamental reasons cannot
do that it's related to girdle's theorem
in mathematics it's related to this
phenomenon i call computational
irreducibility that's a more general
computational phenomenon basically when
you are running a program which is kind
of what we think is going on in
the world um of
things that happen in the world and you
say what's this program going to do
then we know for theoretical reasons
that
it's
you could just see what the program does
after some number of steps but if we say
just tell me what it does in the end
after a trillion steps a quadrillion
steps
you know turns out we can never know the
answer to that except by effectively
following those trillion steps
quadrillion steps whatever sometimes we
can jump ahead but often we cannot now
the fact that we often can't jump ahead
well
the it turns out that that very fact
implies that there are an infinite
number of ways to jump ahead even though
we can't in general jump ahead there are
an infinite number of specific cases in
which we can jump ahead in other words
what that means is if we're trying to
figure out things about how the world
works there are an infinite number of
things we can figure out so called
computationally reducible facts that we
can figure out
even though to figure out everything is
impossible
and that manifests itself in mathematics
as well there's sort of an infinite
frontier of possible theorems you can
prove in mathematics
you'll never run out of theorems at
least in any theory that has the feature
that has computational irreducibility
and any sort of rich interesting
mathematical theory has that feature you
never run out of things to do
the big question is
when you prove that next theorem
when you make that next discovery about
physics when you invent that next
invention the question is does anybody
care
and that's more the question then is
there another thing out there to
discover is that another thing out there
to invent there will always be more
stuff to discover more stuff to invent
the question is when we figure out what
we humans want does it include those new
things so for example in technology we
could say i'm going to invent a thing
that
uh
i don't know
aligns human thoughts
and makes them correspond to the
thoughts of an act
we say right now we'd say that sounds
pretty useless
we don't have a reason to have that
right now but
in
the question is as we look at the
progress of of technology i give a
better example of something technology
we have today a treadmill walking on a
treadmill
okay so let's say you'd invented that
in the middle ages
it's like people look at that and say
why do we want this
what is this what is the point of this
oh it's for taking exercise what do you
mean i can take you know i just walk
around whatever it's like well it's for
taking exercise if you're cooped up
inside and and why do you want to take
exercise well makes you healthier and
all those kinds of things
um i think that the um
uh the question of of what um
um
uh so a lot of what happens is asking
the question
what is the um
uh you know what is the thing
that
uh kind of humans care about to invent
there is an infinite frontier of things
you could invent
the question is which things are in the
path that we humans think we care about
so
uh
let's see so the question was where are
we humans in terms of going from no
knowledge to all knowledge we will never
get to all knowledge
now there are various directions in
which we may reach the edge of knowledge
for example one that i've been much
involved in is do we know fundamentally
how the universe works
i think we're actually finally
actually fairly close to that we know
the underlying rules we don't know what
consequences those rules have it's like
we know the machine code for our
computer but there's an infinite number
of possible programs that be running on
computer and things we can do with our
computer but nevertheless there's a
question sort of in one direction of
knowledge there's a question of do we
know what the machine code for our
universe is and i think we're getting
pretty close to that i think we're at
least in the right going in the right
direction we have the right sort of
formalism we don't know all the details
of how it works out but we know uh much
more closely how that's actually working
and that's kind of my personal and our
excitement over the last couple of years
is figuring out how that works
so
in that sense one sort of border of
knowledge i think we are actually
surprisingly did not think i would see
this in my lifetime i think we're
surprisingly you know at uh you know
we're hitting the edge of that
i think that there are
um
other when we look at
building from that machine code where
can we build to what kinds of things can
we construct in the physical world
well that's an infinite frontier
now
uh we can also ask the question
it's sort of an interesting question
when people learn about stuff
if there's an intimate frontier of
knowledge an infinite frontier of things
to invent how can it be the case that
education remains finite
that is
it could be the case that over the
course of history as we learn more as a
species and so on we invent more it
could just be that we just need to learn
more and more and more stuff
and that sort of you know while we have
right now you know i don't know what it
is uh uh you know
eight years 12 years whatever of
education
that you know that could extend into um
uh
uh you know into some you know you
really need to be educated for 50 years
just to know what's what's known about
how the world works
well
there is a certain sense in which that
is happening because people learn about
narrower and narrower pieces of what
there is to know about everything about
how the world works and how to do things
and so on but actually i think there's a
different phenomenon as well which is
that as time goes forward
more things become abstracted away
so there was a time when to drive a car
you really had to know how car works
you know you had to know oh you have to
you know pump this gas thing to get you
know to fill the fuel line and you had
to know how this works and that works
and the other works
and um uh
you know pretty soon it's just like
press the button to make the car start
turn the key to make the car start
press the gas car will go forward turn
the steering wheel you don't need to
know anything about how you know all
sorts of complicated things in the
engine of the car are working
and so it is with lots of other kinds of
areas that over time more and more gets
automated away and we get to operate at
a sort of higher level of abstraction
both but things get automated and we
don't have to do them technologically
and things get understood better and you
know there was a time when we would have
had to learn
all the different kinds of i don't know
uh
animals maybe of some particular type
and then some classification of animals
is put in place we'd have to learn all
the different kinds of mathematical
curves of a certain type and then
there's a general theory of those things
and so we only have to learn the general
theory we don't need to learn all the
detailed pieces and so there's this
trend towards higher abstraction and
higher automation and that reduces the
amount that you need to know to be able
to operate within those domains of
knowledge in the world and so that's
sort of the the counterbalancing force
to there's just more and more and more
to know
is
more and more is getting sort of
abstracted away
so in terms of what will sort of the
growth of knowledge look like
uh in the future
you know people are fond of saying look
you know we have an uh you know
exponentially increasing amount of sort
of knowledge that's getting written down
in papers about science and things like
this
i'm not sure if that's a great
reflection of what's really going on i
think it's just a question of how many
people are doing science and what are
the mechanisms for getting people to
publish things and so on i'm not sure
that's really a reflection of the true
sort of uh um that the true fundamental
sort of knowledge that's being being
accumulated and what tends to happen in
the accumulation of knowledge is that
what will is that particular areas
suddenly open up whether it's you know
oh now we have the idea of machine
learning now we have the idea of
blockchain now we have the idea of this
fundamental theory of physics these are
things which are in a sense
methodological areas that open up and
much of the progress of the dramatic
progress of knowledge comes when an area
when sort of a new methodological area
opens up and people are able to explore
that and then there's typically a long
period 50 100 years whatever it is when
people are taking that methodological
approach and saying okay we've got the
idea of telescopes let's go use the
telescope to look at all the things we
can see and most of those things are
going to be oh more of the same and then
occasionally there'll be some discovery
made that way but that's actually not
such a good example better examples of
things where one's doing some particular
area of mathematical modeling or
something like this where it's like
we've got this basic idea that all
happened rather suddenly and it
immediately opened up all these
different fields and now we can start
working with them i mean i i will say
that uh just to make a kind of a a pre
thing for this kind of paradigm for
thinking about theoretical science that
i've been working on that has is
something that's a consequence of what
we've discovered in our physics project
it's kind of a different way of
understanding kind of how to make
fundamental models of things
and oh i'll talk about it why not the um
i think one kind of identify
um
the uh
uh
sort of
there are
there are sort of well
okay i'll say this very briefly and
maybe i can talk about it some more in a
different time
the uh it's kind of
in in antiquity the big sort of
realization about making models of
things is that you could that you could
say there's this definite thing the
universe is made of
lots of copies of blah blah blah or you
know it's lots of polyhedra all stuffed
together it's lots of atoms it's lots of
this lots of that it's a kind of
structural statement about what the
universe is made of
that was kind of the first period of
science first big period of science
would just say there is definite
regularity in the universe it's all made
of copies of the same kind of thing
the second big period started in the
1600s when mathematics came in and when
one had the idea of basically writing
down a mathematical equation or a
mathematical formula to represent how
the world works
and the next i think big sort of
paradigmatic change which i have to say
i was personally much involved in in the
1980s um is this 1980s to early 2000s
is kind of the idea of using
programs and computations to represent
what happens in the world so instead of
saying i'm going to write down an
equation and that's going to tell me
everything about how some system is
going to behave that you say i'm going
to write down a program
run the program and you will see what
the system will do
and so it's kind of like you're you're
you're just given a program and the
activity is run the program it's not get
the whole result solve the equation and
answer everything it's rather run the
program and specifically observe what it
does
and so
what happens in those different sort of
paradigms one of the things that happens
is there's a different view of time in
these different paradigms and the kind
of antiquity version the sort of
structural paradigm you don't really
talk about time things are just made of
things it's constructed in this way etc
time is not something that you know
there's some discussion of there there's
a phenomenon that happens through time
but you don't think about dynamics of
change and things like that in time at
least not as directly in the way the
theory is set up
in the kind of mathematical period
time is just a variable a coordinate you
solve the equation time is a variable
that appears you set t equals 3.7 and
you get the answer to what happens at
time 3.7
so that's kind of the notion of time
there in the computational paradigm time
is something where
the actual running of the program is the
progress of time and so there is
something where the model itself
contains sort of an irreducible effort
needed to make progress in time so to
speak
okay so this fourth kind of paradigm is
something that has kind of emerged as an
important thing from our physics project
which is the idea that rather than in
the computational paradigm where you
just have a rule
you have the state of the world you
apply the rule you get the new state of
the world you keep doing that it's kind
of a sequential thing
there's this kind of multi-computational
paradigm that we've realized is the
relevant thing in for understanding
fundamental physics in which you say
i have the state of the world i'm going
to apply a rule in many different ways
i'm going to get many states of the
world and then to those i will apply
rules in many ways and i'll get this
whole multi-way graph we call it of
branching and merging kind of uh
histories of states of the world the
possible states of the world
and i when i say possible that's a weird
word because in some sense i think all
those states of the world actually
happen
and that's kind of the essence in the
end of how quantum mechanics works
but the issue is so in a sense then
whereas the computational paradigm has
this thread of time that is associated
with the progress of computation the
multi-computational paradigm has many
threads of time the many threads of time
branching and merging there's no single
sort of sequential notion of time and
what happens there is that one of the
things is that we humans to understand
things end up needing sequentialization
of time so we in a sense necessarily
extract we necessarily sort of make
equivalent lots of different threads of
time in this kind of multi-computational
point of view and those correspond to
reference frames and relativity and
various things in quantum measurement
and so on more technically but
essentially what's happening is that we
are the observer
we are a necessary piece of this story
because without that it's just like
there are all these different threads of
time we can't tell what's going on if we
want to be able to tell anything about
what's going on to relate it to
something human understandable we have
to sort of sequentialize time we have to
kind of make equivalences that allow us
to have the single thread
that we actually observe
and it turns out when you make that
single thread you actually observe
there are
some
features of what
of the way that the system is
constructed the way this kind of graph
of multiple multi-way graph of branching
and merging pieces of history and so on
there are some inexorable features of
that that are basically a consequence of
the the construction of the whole thing
they don't depend on the details of the
particular rules that you're using to to
figure out what the next state is from
the previous state and so on they are
somehow somewhat generic features and
the fact that we're kind of making these
observations
is a
the the the sort of the simplicity of
the observer forces a certain simplicity
on the kinds of conclusions we can make
even though the underlying system is
doing something very very complicated
and that forcing of simplicity leads to
a bunch of ideas a bunch of approaches
to actually making a kind of a
science where you can explain things out
of a lot of different fields and i'm
just exploring a bunch of these
i think i just added immunology to my
list of immunology and neuroscience to
my list of fields but i think they're
going to be really interesting things to
say with that kind of paradigm
but um uh
and um
i think that the um
uh this is an example of a place where
in a sense this new paradigm will i
think open up a bunch of new kinds of
knowledge and new ways to talk about
knowledge new kinds of questions that
you can ask about things that didn't
exist before if you're just tracking
well did we answer all the questions did
we do all the exercises the answer might
be we did all the exercises from the
last version of what the kinds of
questions were but now we have this new
paradigm that gives us a whole bunch of
new questions we didn't even think of
asking and that's somewhat related to
these questions about technology and
what we humans want in technology
because that's again a did we think we
wanted a treadmill or something
and did we think we wanted to answer
this kind of question that's that's what
gets opened up as we look at these
different areas
of um of knowledge and so on and that's
um that's kind of i think the that's why
it's a little difficult to measure the
progress of knowledge because the
knowledge any time you've got a
measurement mechanism you've probably
you're locking yourself into that old
kind of knowledge not the new kind of
knowledge for which your measurement
doesn't really yet make sense
at least that's my impression here
uh
let's see i need to wrap up soon here
but um uh from rookie what could knowing
the machine code of the universe unlock
in technology
you know
it's an interesting question because i i
sort of was saying
you know it's gonna be hundreds of years
before anything useful comes from
knowing directly for technology and i
was like giving analogies like when
newton was figuring out his universal
law of gravitation you know he knew that
there could be artificial satellites
orbiting the earth
but
he uh he was kind of an investor in
things you know he invested in the south
sea company and all kinds of things like
that but uh had he invested in a rocket
company back in the 1690s or something
it would have been a bad bet
unfortunately his investment in the
south sea company was also a bad bet
but um uh and that's a that's its own uh
bizarre uh more biographical story about
newton but in any case the um so you
know from our physics project it's like
is the only stuff that is in prospect
the like a rocket company seen from 16
you know from the 1690s
um i did figure out that there is some
theoretical possibility of things like
faster than light travel
that
it becomes something which is an a sort
of a quotes engineering problem rather
than a physics problem although to us
today it looks like an absolutely
uninsurmountable engineering problem but
that's probably what satellite launches
looked like in 1690
so
the thing that's strange about our
physics project is that it actually has
even a year later it's starting to have
applications and it's like how can that
be well the answer is its methodology is
starting to have applications like its
method of defining how you solve the
einstein equations for relativity for
general relativity and gravity and
describe you know mergers of black holes
and things like that we can use our
models to get a new way to solve those
kinds of equations we can use our models
to get a better way to optimize quantum
computing circuits and things those are
things which come out of our models as a
formal matter it's not a question of i'm
going to build a device it's a question
of i'm going to use this as part of
figuring out how to do other kinds of
things sort of almost as a a better
mathematics so to speak rather than a
better technology it's a better
mathematical technology rather than a
better physical technology so to speak
and i think we're seeing the same kind
of thing particularly in distributed
computing and probably distributed
blockchain of a physics-informed
approach to those areas the big thing is
that in an area like distributed
computing
um it's again it's part of what is the
question like you you say you've got all
these processes that all running
separately what do you want it to do
well
you can
the thing that happens is because of
this interplay with physics we can use
this vast amount of knowledge that has
been accumulated in physics to kind of
inform our intuition about what it's
possible to do with distributed
computing and that's i think a really
fertile area a place where we will see a
bunch of applications in the very near
term to our physics project even though
they're not directly uh sort of physical
things they're not like building a giant
particle accelerator or doing something
like that i mean there will be things
that we might be able to see as pieces
of experiments of seeing things about
the cosmic microwave background from the
beginning of the universe or seeing
things about particular kinds of black
holes and so on but those are not
technological applications anytime soon
i mean i think the there may come a
moment at some point in the future of
our civilization when black holes become
a technological component they're
certainly not there yet
all right i think um
we should
wrap up here
lots of interesting questions a good
place to start for next time
so
thanks for joining me and see you next
time